in this video we'll talk about the HPA
axis which is hypothalamus pituitary
adrenal axis this is a major
neuroendocrine system that regulates
body's reaction towards stress so it
involves hypothalamus pituitary and the
adrenal gland
now let's try to understand how this
overall axis works and what are the
function of these HPA axes
so first of all from the hypothalamus
there is a hormone known as
corticotropine releasing hormone or crh
which is secreted and ultimately it
leads to the secretion of ACTH or
adrenal corticotropic hormone secretion
adrenal corticotropic hormone can go to
the adrenal gland and it leads to the
secretion of several uh
corticosteroids including cortisol
cortisol is the key hormone that
regulates body's response towards stress
it lead to several metabolic and
immunologic changes anyway after a while
when cortisol levels are too high body
need to tone it down and thereby there
is a negative feedback on pituitary and
hypothalamus so this is the overall HPI
axis in a nutshell now let's try to
understand this in a bit more details so
in the hypothalamus there are several
nuclear regions so one of the
neuroendocrine region is paraventricular
nucleus shown here now crh is actually
secreted by the neurons of
paraventricular nucleus
crh is released in response of stress
and it's a I mean amino acid
containing proteins has like 41 amino
acids
so overall
corticotropine releasing hormone
acts on pituitary
so if we cut a cross section of the
pituitary there are several regions
inside the anterior pituitary and one of
the region is known as corticotrope
cells this corticotrop cell lead to
production of the ACTH hormone
so the corticotropine releasing hormone
binds to the specific crh receptors
which are G protein coupled receptors on
the membranes of corticotrop cells
eventually that lead to secretion of the
ACTH hormone which is basically 39 amino
acid long peptide hormone eventually
this particular hormone acts on the
adrenal cortex and lead to the secretion
of cortisol
anyway the specific region which
produces corticosteroid is known as
zoonophysicophesicular of the adrenal
cortex
now
how exactly ACTH is working ACTH is
again a peptide type of hormone it binds
to G protein couple receptor present on
the
Zona fasciculata cells now it leads to
exchange of GTP in place of GTP and the
g protein gets activated which in turns
activates adenylate cyclist which leads
to production of cyclic amp thereby
activation of protein kinase a protein
kinase a can have long term and
short-term effects protein kinase a can
move into the nucleus lead to production
of genes that are responsible for the
metabolism of the cortisol or
corticosteroids overall steroid hormone
biogenesis and also the pka lead to
short-term changes or immediate changes
in order of seconds to minutes these
changes allow cholesterol to get inside
the cell once cholesterol is inside the
cell steroid hormone can be produced
remember that all these corticosteroid
has a common precursor pool which is the
cholesterol they are all cholesterol
derivatives because they are steroids
now cortisol has wide variety of effect
on liver adipose tissue muscles and many
other organs anyway in the liver it
breaks down glycogen so it kind of lead
to glycogenolysis and prevents the
process of glycogenesis so it ensures
that enough amount of glucose is present
in the bloodstream during the stress
because body need to respond towards
that stress our brain need to work in
that stressful situation so huge amount
of blood glucose Supply is necessary
also as per a second energy source
adipose tissue is affected by cortisol
so adipose tissue has stored fat which
gets converted to free fatty acid
eventually these free fatty acids can be
broken down to produce energy
and then in the muscle there are
catabolic reactions which are favored
for example breakdown of protein is
favored and anabolism of protein is
prevented now many of these uh building
blocks of protein can be used to
generate glucose further
so overall what we understand cortisol
lead to a widespread changes in the
metabolism of the body
anyway
cortisol also affects the immune system
and suppress it and thereby regulates a
balance between inflammation and
infection so cortisol decreases
inflammation but increases the risk of
infection it's a potent
immunosuppressant so it is good when
somebody is undergoing a graft rejection
let's say so when somebody has taken a
draft there are high chances that their
immune system is going to reject that
particular Graft in order to prevent
that generally cortisol injections are
given so cortisol suppresses the immune
system and prevent The graft rejection
in many cases cortisol specially
inhibits the inflammatory cytokines and
promotes the production of
anti-inflammatory cytokines such as
interleukin-10 and thereby it leads to
its biological effect of
immunosuppression
anyway too much cortisol is also not
good so body has to maintain a
homeostatic level of cortisol or overall
corticosteroid too much cortisol is seen
in Cushing syndrome which is associated
with many problems
other than that people who are
undergoing kind of adrenal gland tumors
or people might be in corticosteroids
they might show high level of cortisol
which has adverse effect on the body
let's see how the negative feedback loop
works in the HP axis because for any
hormonal Axis or any kind of regulated
system a negative feedback loop is
really important here the negative
feedback loop starts with high level of
cortisol in the blood so when the
cortisol level is too high it gives a
negative feedback on the pituitary first
it prevents the secretion of ACTH when
ACTH is low adrenal gland would produce
less and less corticosteroids eventually
for the long term suppression it leads
to a negative feedback into the
hypothalamus so it's basically a
top-down control which is targeted by
too much level of cortisol
that pretty much summarized the HP axis
and its regulation so if you like this
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe you
can uh get more notes and uh flash cards
in my Facebook page follow us on
Instagram you can support our Channel
using super tanks option you can pay via
paytm Paypal UPI Etc see you in next
video